دعوة عاطفية للعمل من اثنين من
العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية
الذين يقولون إن مرضاهم غير الملقحين
يأسفون على عدم تلقي جرعة covet 19 التي
أدخلوها إلى النظام وفي
وقت مبكر
قالوا هل يمكنني تلقيحها وفي
هذه المرحلة لا
يمكنك الحصول عليها بالفعل  الأعراض التي لا يمكنك
الحصول عليها ، تقول أليكس زاركوفسكي
، مديرة التمريض الإكلينيكي للعناية المركزة
في نظام جاكسون الصحي في ميامي ،
إنها تتعامل مع مجموعة صغيرة جدًا
من المرضى المغطاة
الذين يموتون في أوائل العشرينات من منتصف
العشرينات من
الثلاثينيات والأربعينيات والخمسينيات من العمر
19 إصابات تطمع
وتتزايد حالات الاستشفاء في جميع أنحاء الولايات المتحدة ، تُظهر
البيانات الواردة من مركز السيطرة على الأمراض أن الولايات المتحدة تبلغ في
المتوسط أكثر من 40 أ
ف حالة كوبين جديدة كل يو
.  coven 19. أحد
آخر الأشياء التي
يقومون بها قبل التنبيب هو التوسل إلي من أجل اللقاح الذي أمسكه
بيديهم وأخبرهم أنني
آسف على ذلك.  لقد فات الأوان ،
تكتب الدكتورة كوبيا أيضًا أنه عندما
لا ينجح المرضى ،
فإنها تخبر أفراد الأسرة بتكريم
أحبائهم من خلال التطعيم
وتشجيع الآخرين على القيام بذلك أيضًا ،
إنها نفس الرسالة القادمة من الآخرين في
الخطوط الأمامية
نحصل على اللقطة.  أريد حقًا التأكد من أن
الجميع يفهم أننا
بحاجة حقًا إلى مساعدتك لمساعدتك
في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم
أنا ماري مالوني